here is um here's uh oh
god here we go parents are out of town
so you know when the uh the cat's away
dayton will play with tinfoil
i'm getting a video to show uh this is
my
parent's bedroom in our house wait what
whoa whoa he went into his parents
bedroom and why do you know me
why why because he wants to show the
place where the evil overlords that
helped his brother beat him is it not
customary right for like people to be
uncomfortable with people being in their
bedroom of course nobody likes it like
i have a decent bedroom like i bought a
nice bedroom set my bedroom's nice but
like
i don't water bed yeah old school stuff
remember those in high school or sleep
you have in your life is on a water bed
they were cool to lay on when you were
awake yeah of course but then when you
have you can't sleep on those
turn i didn't just roll off i hate water
beds
uh but no like you don't i don't know
man it's like certain things i don't go
into people's bedrooms unless they
tell me like hey can you go up there and
grab the thing in the bedroom all right
yeah i got you
i purses are the other thing i don't
even if i'm dating a girl and they go go
in my prayer i'm like i'll bring you
your purse
and you're going and you go in your own
part there's certain things i've always
been weird about and
it's just odd he's always snooping
around
in our house so i don't think i've ever
gotten
video of the room in here uh
in broad daylight i think i only got a
video of the house when it was darker
why would you need to get video of the
room so i didn't really come in here for
more than a moment when i filmed that um
because it was pretty dark in here and
all the
all the curtains were closed and right
now they all still are except for like
the ones facing that way so anyway i'm
just gonna get a video real quick
interesting stuff like this is in the
mirror
in my mom's uh you know dresser in here
so no wonder your brother beat you
you kind of try not to bump into
anything when you're
showing you know how you wouldn't bump
into anything if you weren't in there
yeah
filming that would probably help try not
to bump into anything while i'm
secretly filming my parents bedroom
all of this that's outside
uh so let's see
there's just another mirror over there
and stuff so
um this is a couch it's kind of a mess
in here honestly but
yeah i'm just showing that really
it's a door to the hallway there
some other chairs in here fireplace and
stuff
yeah that's kind of a mess though
he makes me mad he makes me [ __ ] mad
dude
what a piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] he is well
i mean we say this
i love how we we still say this and
we're both still so good
oh can you believe this guy and at this
point we're like yeah yeah
it's just what he is his brother dies he
was snooping around his room the next
day
before the body was even cold i'm just
showing the room
for a moment this is the window to the
backyard
and you can hear the pond out there i
think
i have a question um
[Music]
who gives a [ __ ] what does this have to
do even if let's say you
would believe your wild fairies that you
were getting beat in the house by a
skinhead
what does your parents bedroom have to
do with anything
i love that mirror actually it's really
nice she has some nice mirrors
so yeah i have a big bedroom my parents
bedroom
it's like probably the
this might be like the third largest
room in the house
i think it's oh maybe he's a realtor now
oh is that what he's doing yeah yeah
hyper
open house yeah yeah just a little bit
better i'm going to be doing digital
showings okay if you want to look at
this
lovely split floor plan
it has new england style window
treatments and
shutters kitchen
or maybe it's around the same size so
it's just it's also two and a half bath
but the half bath technically it has a
shower stall so it's not even a half
it's
really you're getting three bathrooms
for the price of a two and a half baths
that's really cool
okay
when you have the house to yourself this
is what you do
just mutter with your [ __ ] camera
you're not even gonna do like a little
uh risky business
play some old town rockets
nothing that's in here too steven wright
realty they're calling it
come check out a split floor plan dual
ranch
duplex it's got two bathrooms
bob's got a good point he's just showing
his future tinder dates where they will
be mating
[Laughter]
also features a two-car garage
but you could technically put one car in
there and then have a bunch of tools
anyway this is usually where i'm i come
to record videos to talk
and you know that filthy mirror
that mirror has a [ __ ] an inch thick
thing of grime on it why
this is what's up because i'm gonna
break this down no you're right
obviously we agree he sucks but he
no longer has the super villain that was
sherman
so now all he could do is just he's p he
doesn't know what to do
he's just [ __ ] filming his parents
bedroom and making baked potato rooms
like how long before his brother's ghost
was beating him oh god that'd be amazing
i left
my camera on all night in case because i
wanted to catch
my brother's ghost this is coming and
beating me i'm doing a seance this
evening
and i'm going to order one pizza for all
the people that are coming over to the
seance
we got a ouija board because my skinhead
brother
this beats me
deep mr devil money has a great question
how old is this flaky sloth
flakey he's liberating him for two years
he's 35 flaky sloth might be one of the
most
amazing descriptions of [ __ ] earl
i've ever heard
he's 35 years old he's slop
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] man oh [ __ ] he's so much
fun to [ __ ] on i you know
cause like we'll goof on people
sometimes and we'll feel bad because
you're like that guy's probably all
right of course
but like this one's always a guilt-free
let's put the boots to this prick for 40
minutes i never feel bad
i cannot stand this man we have like
five good solid people we cover on the
show that i go to bed
guilt-free at night for ripping them
apart because you're like that person
sucks
they're terrible he has never done one
redeeming thing no
even when we were covering like here's a
good example like fighter and the kid
right when we covered them
there are some things that callan does
where it's there's redeemable things
where you're like
you know he kind of got [ __ ] over that
woman lied like that's some [ __ ]
like i feel bad for him that like
his entire even if you don't like him
his entire career is [ __ ] over because
some broad decided to lie because
we still hate brian cowan but right you
know there's moments where you go okay
it's not that bad like yeah it's
just not as hateable as 19 other guys in
that room
but yeah like between this guy and uh
but that's why we always hate like
talk about hating dayton because it's
like we always compare him to thomas
murphy
thomas murphy has issues that for most
people would be
severely limiting of course and like you
know what i mean he's got way more
issues than
dayton does as far as like things that
might set him back
but he's just plucky and upbeat and he
goes to his job and he you know might
sometimes he might refuse to put away
the frozen food stuff
stick in a cart somewhere sometimes
sometimes he makes a mistake now and
again he
microwaves a little hand sanitizer but
even the most psychotic [ __ ] thomas
murphy does is like harmless
he might break a 20 [ __ ] walmart
microwave to defend thomas murphy
he was angry because taylor swift was
playing that's a good point